all right
imagine this you're 16 years old you're
incredible at cs go
and you're demolishing some of the best
players of
all time this is a good round for my brs
are out this is what you want to blind
that guy from
his initial vision but how is he able to
get through there
they need to be scaling out of the
balcony that one guy big pit but when
the game ends
after you win people aren't singing your
praises
instead all you get are death threats
nathan leif orf was once one of the most
promising young
up-and-coming cs go players in the world
he came out of nowhere and
everyone was talking about him leaf he
could do this if he just stops the bomb
but
it seems like nobody's going to check
him leaf swings and leaf stops it
now he's going for the third and leaf
will take it all
but then everything changed i do still
think like the clips are suspicious but
it's not really in my right to
do anything about it the only reason
he's getting called out for cheese right
now is because they're no namers they've
never seen him play or how can they
judge him
but leaf didn't take the cheating
accusations lying down
he blasted his haters in one game and
then did it again
in another spot for something special
here he gets one gets two
looking for more he's gonna get flashed
up tries to get to safety
but mitch is there with the cross leaf
gets a third he was working with
practically nothing there other than his
aim but that's all
leaf needs
if you've heard anything about leaf over
the last couple of months it's probably
one of three things
that he was once one of na's most
exciting cs go prospects
that he was falsely accused of cheating
or that he's one of the most
unlucky players in esports but things
didn't start out that way
leaf began his cs go journey in 2018
making a name for himself on faceit and
esea
we're gonna charge up our side lots of
mdl experience on blitz reborn side four
players having played an mdl before us
loner gonna get that frag
over on swan leaf finds spongy as well
if you peek out mid hello you're just
gonna walk right into a firing squad
that's gonna initiate the push for the
keysight here leaf will be leading the
charge onto the a site
made out leaf tagged down to a single
point of health
unbelievable that he's staying alive
right now despite being just
15 years old at the time leaf rose to
the ranks of amateur cs pretty
quickly he hop between a bunch of
up-and-coming rosters and always stood
out as one of the best players on the
server
down to two leith has the mp9 long range
he's able to take down two
now it's b wheels but the sg trying to
shut down the streak from leaf to try to
take this map for under 21.
in a spray he's able to at least get
that burst
leaf are you kidding me and look at this
setup here twice
he's gonna be trapped over to the boiler
area but leaf is gonna catch two
trapped because of his flash and once
again he's gonna go for some more
four kills for leap leaf was actually so
talented that halfway through 2020
chaos esports club one of any scrappiest
orgs took a chance on him
and he did not disappoint leif
is looking to prove himself as he has no
teammates to help him survive
20 seconds on the clock leaf
he could do this if he just stops the
bomb but it seems like nobody's gonna
check him
leaf swings and the leaf stops it now
he's going for the third and leaf will
take it
all this leaf is razor sharp man that is
such
a big play it's two big plays zeppa and
leaf to get combined for five kills that
was chaos
dumpstering mibr and you have to
understand that that was a
big deal you see back in the day mibr
was one of the most
legendary rosters in cs go these were
two-time major winners who
took the cs world by storm just a few
years earlier
but time hadn't been kind to mibr's old
gods
and surely that form they need it down
right now fur is gonna be
in safety he can't swing for it here
they do line up at all
and it's a 500 000 dollar comeback for
mad lions
on train outrageous so when
leaf took apart mibr to secure a tie
at the blast premier spring showdown the
famously
feral brazilian community kind of went
nuts
they're already going to be met by
fallen awp and he collaterals them
oh my goodness mibr
they make it happen six rounds in a row
a ridiculous one versus two from trk
and the resilience from the brazilians
is enough to tie this up and then a few
weeks later
chaos and mibr faced off again this time
at cs summit 6 where
things were closed until chaos pulled
ahead and leaf
went crazy not planning for him
oh oh boy he doesn't have a kid either
oh
boy oh my goodness oh
been killed by taco there now they know
that everything's going to be in front
of them but leaf the young guy you're
talking about
[Music]
oh yeah this is a good round for my br's
are out this is what you want to blind
that guy from
his initial vision but how is he able to
get through there
they need to be scaling out of the
balcony that one guy big pit
and leaf just doing a great job
the issue was that as far as the
brazilian fans were concerned
leaf had gone a little too crazy this is
very tough because they know last year
come from respond they got the deep
smoke thrown and the gg
is about to be thrown at us chaos toss a
massive upset here
to start off n a feeling righteous as
soon as the series ended
social media exploded brazilian fans
were outraged at what they considered an
unthinkable loss and they started to
accuse leaf of
cheating i was gonna say he needs to
kill him to absolutely kind of push in
but it doesn't really happen
4v5 has turned back into a 4v4 here they
are on the bomb site with the potential
to get positive trades here
they even threw zeppa one of leaf's
teammates into the mix claiming that
he'd used an
aim lock but things were about to get
even
worse mibr's longtime opera and in-game
leader fallen
seemed to support the accusations
against leith and
that only added more fuel to the fire so
basically what happened that day is
we're playing this game against chaos i
didn't feel anything different during
the game to be honest and
normally you're playing a bl3 you're not
checking social media you're not doing
anything like that you're just playing
the game
and we lost the game and there wasn't
anything different from from normal from
the gaming perspective from a player
inside the server
and when i jumped into social media to
start posting hey we lost the game and
started updating people
i saw a lot of people like the brazilian
community was reacting a lot
about some suspicious clips on the
internet right and then i was like yeah
sometimes they do it even like now
against vp like there's some people hey
jane was looking weird
you know those kind of comments they are
always there and on that situation
against chaos
there was like two or three clips that
on my opinion are suspicious and it's
fine like there will be many suspicious
clips on the internet
and they have but some statistics for
myself in the past even on lan
tournaments so those things will happen
and even though fallen did eventually
back off the damage had been
done and my mistake on that day is that
i actually saw
derek posting about it and then that's
when i took the wrong conclusions like
dude this really is real like
someone else like a player who actually
knows a lot about the game
too is actually finding this suspicious
too and then on the head of the moment i
was like dude this actually looks very
suspicious that's what i wanted to say
on my pulse right
and then i realized that by saying that
i was basically
validating everyone's opinion that this
guy was using something for sure which
is not fair for my side so
right after two or three minutes i think
someone called me out on twitter say hey
dude
watch out like whether he's not cool and
then i went out and said hey i'm sorry
i'm delighting my post like this is not
how i should be behaving right so
i think i have my my rights to find any
future species in the end or not but
definitely approaching on social media
wasn't the best way to put it
and it might be unfair in some
situations so i'm sorry for that
then brazilian super streamer galvest
got involved his live stream or as he
called it the tribunal of justice
brought guests on to scrutinize the
so-called criminal clips that chaos had
produced
clips that according to some weren't
even all that incriminating but it looks
like his arm stuck out a bit
as well and there wasn't even on his
head
why are you guys causing all this drama
the only reason
he's getting called out for cheese right
now is because they're no namers they've
never seen him play how can they judge
him
let's say you're a brazilian you're a
hardcore mibr
fan and your team loses to some
no-namers i'd be pissed too right
before we go any further it really can't
be overstated just how big a deal
cheating accusations
are in esports it's one of the highest
crimes you can accuse a player of
and whether they're true or not they can
ruin a young player's career
over the years there have been plenty of
stars who are accused of cheating and
succeeded anyway
but there are many more talented
up-and-comers who were falsely accused
and just
couldn't play through the accusations
and some people
didn't want leaf to end up like them
casters community members competitors
everybody jumped in to defend chaos and
a small youtuber named opsy
even offered a more technical
explanation for those clips
and he flicks we turn wireframe on
we can see that the game's engine is not
rendering where fur is right now
it's rendering library it's rendering
boiler it's rendering some of apartments
but it is not rendering where fur is
meaning that wallhacks
or any hacks could not detect fur
through the wall unfortunately
there were legions of brazilian fans who
refused to believe that leaf didn't
cheat
and they took things way too far leaf
his teammates and chaos were all facing
an endless string of accusations and
harassment
instead of getting to celebrate their
win they were getting
literal death threats even tarik who
continued to doubt if leaf was legit
made it clear that the threats were
unacceptable and downright shameful
i do still think like the clips are
suspicious but
obviously um it's not really
in my right to do anything about it
and i definitely didn't mean for it to
blow up like this
like uh him getting death threats or
just like
the entire brazilian community just
throwing or like kind of overreacting i
guess but as the cs go community became
more and more critical of the most
extreme brazilian fans they totally
doubled down
eventually though after the community
backlash got so intense
everyone who accused the leaf of hacking
against mibr began to backpedal and
issued apologies and as for relief well
after being basically forced into hiding
by all the threats
he did the only thing he could do prove
the haters
wrong we've got rifles galore now on the
seat he's
limited armor but still plenty there
leaf has to do something
incredible to save this now gratis
faction tries to make the play but leaf
with just three hp he's doing everything
he can and as a has just been outplayed
leaf just absolutely run rings around
does he really just go through a smoke
to try and get bomb back i
doubt it he has to use that smoke as a
brief reprieve
goes aggressively sponged he puts his
head in the way of the bullets never
advisable but trying to save the life
visit of his author
junior is still alive but not for much
longer and our penny and moose
once that smoke clears and disperses the
two of them are on each other's side of
that smoke and finally it clears and
leaf comes in with a couple more
there's the ace and there's a fourth
round for chaos after a top four finish
at esl one cologne north america
chaos took home trophies in both the
north american divisions of iem beijing
and dreamhack masters winter by the end
of the year chaos had solidified
themselves as a top
20 team in the world two left alive the
defuse on the cards but they're not on
the bomb just yet
the headshot is landed by zepha and
chaos get it done
we may not know what the future holds
for this lineup but it'll be a damn
shame if we don't see what else they
have to show us
back-to-back north american championship
titles
they were grinding their way to the top
and it may have sadly been cut short
no matter what happens next they can be
proud of what they've done here today
chaos are your dreamhack masters winter
2020
champions unfortunately the global
pandemic all but annihilated north
american cs go
without any real events sponsor money
was drying up and
chaos was forced to close their doors
leaf entered the new year without a team
and without any real hope of continuing
his pro career
in cs go so like many of his compatriots
leaf had no choice
but to turn to valorant hey guys it's
nathan orf i go by the alias leaf and
i'm going to be joining
c9 i'd probably like to be one of the
top players in the game i definitely
think i have the capabilities to be so i
was
a pretty decent cs player if i don't say
so myself
definitely achievable to be one of the
top players in the game
and he was not about to let his second
chance go to waste
he's gonna be the first one there going
in through b long we'll see if he gets
in on the action as curry takes care of
midge elsewhere on the map
these days holding that flank oh leaf
leaf doesn't dirty they're expecting to
have
as an ace in their sleeve on this icebox
pick because
you know not every team in the game is
get it
and that is a skill jump aftershocks
gonna come out
but it's actually cute fat boy to peak
leap is again with another one and lead
finding a third does leaf get the 4k
going to the sidearms
there we go why not leave incredible
performance
yet again in the round in just two short
months leaf has cemented himself as not
only the star of his new roster
but also one of the hottest talents in
valorant
he's here with his partner in crime leaf
takes down mina he knows that there's
another player there
player in hookah has to try to do
something now
and lee just takes them all down 4k for
leaf
he was working with practically nothing
there other than his aim but that's all
leaf needs the way that leaf was treated
by the cs go community will
follow him forever but the fact that
even through all that he
still wants to compete is a testament to
who he is as a player
and as a person whatever the future
holds relief one thing is for certain
he silenced his haters by rising above
them
by keeping his head down and grinding it
out by
letting his play do the talking by
showing everyone that
no amount of bullying could stop him
from reaching the top
of something special here he gets one
gets two looking for more he's gonna get
flashed up
tries to get to safety but mitch is
there with the cross leaf gets a third
cloud9 play this round beautifully
spectacularly
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages